[Music]
just getting texts in the break from
friends who live in washington dc where
i spent 30 years people being shot
all over the city totally third world
place people living on the streets by
the
thousands do any members of congress who
are worried about q a notice this does
michael mccall notice this what is
happening to our capital city they're
allowing it to happen
nothing's more infuriating than that
except maybe what's happening to dr
seuss
because if it could happen to dr seuss
it might happen to you
dr seuss went from being a beloved
childhood author to
worse than hitler in just a matter of
days on ebay you are allowed to shop for
copies of mineconf
you can buy all the racist filth you
want if it's about white fragility
robin d'angelo wrote it but a number of
dr
seuss books have been purged for quote
offensive imagery
a spokesman from ebay put it this way
quote ebay is currently sweeping our
marketplace to remove these items
so now you're not even allowed to buy a
used copy of dr
seuss's books it's just too dangerous
matt walsh is the host of the matt walsh
show he joins us tonight to explain what
this means
matt thanks so much for coming on i
can't believe hey i'm defending dr susan
b i think it's the big deal that i think
it is but i don't think i've seen a more
depressing story
i don't know when then ebay is making it
impossible to buy used copies of dr
seuss books like what what does this
portend seriously
yeah that's the thing it's not it's not
just about dr seuss by the way i thought
that if the left
was ever going to come after dr seuss
would be it'd be for like
promoting elder abuse with hop on pop or
something like that but
they chose an even more an even more
absurd reason and it's but it's not just
dr seuss the point is we have these
major corporations
that now have the ability and are
exercising that ability to shut down
speech that they find offensive um and
and the question is not whether oh do
they have the right to do it i think
that's totally the wrong question
is it good for the country when major
corporations can
look at entire categories of speech and
say well you're not allowed to see that
anymore or read that
you can't read that book to your child
anymore we're just going to get rid of
that
is that is that a good situation for the
country i think obviously not
we ceded so much control to extremists
without even knowing if you're banning
dr seuss from ebay you are by definition
an extremist i mean that's what an
extremist is
and yet they control our ability to buy
books
and to listen to music and they control
our pictures and everything we've ever
written on the cloud and like they
control
everything why didn't we realize we
might come to a day like this
yeah well that's a good question and the
the point also is that if amazon
and ebay and these other companies say
well we're not going to we're not going
to call doctor who's a conservative
author but
they've also been doing that where
they've been shutting down conservative
books and saying that's hate speech
well if amazon just makes a blanket
policy and says well conservative books
are
uh hate speech then that means that
those books aren't going to be published
anymore because publishers are going to
say there's no point in publishing a
book
that isn't going to be distributed and
that means that that speech is just
shut down entirely that's why the daily
wire just did a poll in fact and found
that two-thirds of americans are opposed
to this kind of
woke-ism from corporate america for this
very reason by the way you also
mentioned
you know this is all happening with dr
seuss all at once
that's that's a good point because dr
seuss lived a hundred years ago his
books
some of these books that are being being
banned right now have been in
publication for 80 years yet
we just decided right now that it's a
problem
like all just like over the summer we
decided that like a thousand
statues all of a sudden have to be torn
down
all at once what does that tell you it
tells you that it's this is
mass hysteria that's that's what this is
and it should be
if for no other reason there are a lot
of reasons to oppose it but we could
oppose it simply on the fact that it's
mass hysteria um where all of these
things are being taken down all at once
but with a purpose i mean they're
demanding that you disavow your own
ancestors that you hate your own country
that you know you hate the books you
read to your own children
i mean it's deep i think i appreciate
your coming on tonight matt matt walsh
thanks a lot